I trusted you enough that I was going to
drive to your house to do a
podcast which I never I I tried to get
out of it three times I said what don't
you zoom like or any other
podcast where you think there's no
cameras then I find out there are
cameras it's got to be in person it's
just I feel you I hear you but you dug
in on it I had to well when I like
someone I'm like I gotta have them as a
guest and you know not all guests are
that open
um not all the guests are you know but
give it the list of the people that you
had when I rolled through some of I mean
they're all great they're all great but
I mean I checked in I told you I checked
on Nathan right I texted him this
morning and I checked it on WWE Will
Wheaton and they both said oh please say
hi to me so great he's so self-effacing
he's so prepared he so they both said
glowing about you that's awesome it
really is that's really nice by the way
working with Will did you know a lot of
like the stuff because he's obviously an
open book hence his books up there you
know did you know a lot of the things
that were going on personally in his
life at all he kept it from everybody
well and his parents were there and we
thought it was a copacetic family we
thought everything was hunky-dory that
they were just quiet
we had no idea until he started to go
through whatever he went through to find
he by the way is great at this have you
seen ready room yeah I saw you on there
yeah he's really really he's just so
important to it well read and so like
does the research does knows what he's
talking what you do too he's also got
what you he makes us comfortable
he's also very present which he's which
is essential I think it is in this job
and
he really loves Star Trek he does he
told me those stories where he would go
in early and look at the ship and go in
there before he even started working and
all that were you was that a parent were
you like this kid just wow this kid's no
he didn't feel like a kid to us
I'll tell you this is a story that I
tell all the time but I'll share it with
you so that you can have it in your in
your table that repertoire repertoire
you've probably heard it already no when
he he grew up in the show obviously
right so he turned
started when he was 13 maybe so he
turned 16 he got a driver license and
enough money he bought a bought a Honda
Civic which was the same car that
Patrick drove at the time right wow so
we finished work together at uh we spent
at the same time when they were walking
out of the out of the sounds tape to go
to where our cars were parked and um
he's feeling he's full of himself right
he's 16 years old he's he's got a car
he's going to the parking garage he's
gonna drive his car home he just worked
on his team so uh we're walking back to
the garage she says you know Fricks
I could tell by the clothes that you
wear and the music comes out of your
dressing room
you used to be cool didn't you oh my God
you never heard that story before that's
one of my big convention stories he said
that oh and I quote him and I bust his
balls for it every time what did you say
at the time did you laugh of course I
laughed I'm just being like you kid
exactly I think I laughed with the
you kid but uh so he he's I I never let
him live it down he's amazing he's an
amazing human being he really is and I
just you know it's tragic it's like
hearing that story where he sent a
letter to his parents and and said
everything and they just didn't respond
I know and it just did you do you
remember reaching out to him at all
saying hey if I'm here if you need me no
we said that in how we behaved to him
which is what it makes him say to us
that we were his family he we treated
him as an equal I think in a way that he
wasn't treated maybe on some other
maybe at home right which we'd none of
us knew and I always think of myself as
a pretty good Observer of human behavior
we were all in the dark about it we've
and we've talked about it privately
behind us back and said did you
know I didn't know another idea
but he is so eloquent about the
relationship how important that his
relationship is with us and we with him
yeah he brings when we're together in
that rare time we get to do a panel with
everybody
he brings a level
of sincerity to the panel and it
informed he's so informed
that doesn't allow us to get sarcastic
or
what's the word I'm looking for with you
um you've you've done this surface yeah
yes he doesn't allow any of us to go
into that Pat kind of answer world
because he's sincere and he and he wants
and he listens and he's a very special
man